حيث افادت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه بارتفاع
عدد شهداء الغارات الاسرائيلي على القطاع
الى 13 بينهم اربعه اطفال واربع نساء
والاصابات العشرين ومن بين الشهداء ثلاثه
من قاده سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه
الجهاد الاسلاميه
وزوجاتهم وعدد من ابنائهم هذا وقالت سرايا
القدسنا القاده هم جهاد الغنام امينو سر
المجلس العسكري لسرايا القدس وخليل
البهتيني عضو المجلس العسكري وقائد
المنطقه الشماليه في القطاع وطارق عز
الدين احد وقاده العمل العسكري لسرايا
القدس في الضفه الغربيه واقل المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي انهم حققوا كل اهداف
العمليه فجر اليوم في غزه
وقد نشر الجيش الاسرائيلي صورا قال انها
للغارات التي نفذها على القطاع